Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 65. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ihr seid wieder live dabei, wenn es geht um Dinge, die die Welt bewegen oder bewegen müssten. Und heute haben wir ein Bastelthema. Es geht um ganz konkretes Hands-on-Hacking, selber machen, selber was bauen und wir steigen ein wenig ein in das 21. Jahrhundert, was uns mal wieder eine interessante neue Technikrevolution beschert, ausgehend davon, dass bestimmte Dinge, die man schon immer haben wollte, erschwinglich oder bzw. leistungsfähiger werden, sodass man langsam darüber nachdenken kann, nicht nur davon zu träumen, so etwas zu haben, sondern dass man wirklich den Schraubenzieher auspacken kann und sich das selber zusammenstecken kann. Die Rede ist von elektrischen Fahrrädern oder generell elektrisch betriebenen Urban-Lifestyle-Devices, die einen durch die Stadt bringen. Den Traum gibt es ja schon lange. Und jemand, der sich diesen Traum ein wenig gerade erfüllt, ist Gizmo. Hallo Gizmo.
Hallo Tim.
Guten Tag, willkommen bei Chaosradio Express. Du bist in diesem Bereich umtriebig. Seit wann beschäftigst du dich mit dem Thema?
Es sind jetzt gut zwei Jahre. Das war fleißig Elektrofahrräder und Pedelecs bauen und damit auf den Straßen unterwegs sind. Das fing langsam an mit einem einzelnen Fahrzeug, das ich für die Arbeit verwenden wollte, um das Computing, wie du es vorhin nanntest.
Du warst einfach faul.
Ja, ich war faul. Fahrrad treten selber macht nicht so viel Spaß.
Die Faulheit ist ja häufig der Motor interessanter neuer Entwicklung. Insbesondere im Computerbereich.
Gerade hier im Fahrzeugbau trifft das wohl auch zu.
Ja, und es ist ja auch so dieser Traum der Mobilität. Wir hatten ja gerade vor ein paar Ausgaben bei Chaosradio Express hier den Retro-Futurismus, der ja auch sozusagen diesen Blick in die Vergangenheit auch gewagt hat. Oder sagen wir mal dieses Phänomen des in diese Vergangenheit blicken, wie man damals so die Zukunft gesehen hat. Und was halt auch immer dabei war, waren halt so Personal-Devices, ja möglichst mobil sein, unabhängig sein. Da war es dann meistens noch mehr vom Auto getragen, aber...
Der kleine Gleiter für die Stadt.
Aber genau, der kleine Gleiter, der kleine Scooter, das fliegende Mobil oder auch so schienenbasierte Systeme sind immer wieder so Teil dieses Traums.
Ganz tolle futuristische Fantasien.
Und das hat dich auch getrieben sozusagen.
Ja, also klar, es hat sich mit neuer Technik angeboten, da einzusteigen. Interessant genug war es. Benzin hatten wir nicht wirklich Lust, da noch weiter zu machen. Das ist also wirklich der anderen überlassen. Und das war eigentlich so der Hauptantrieb.
Gibt es ein Vier? Bist du da alleine am Schaffen?
Ja, ich spreche öfter genug von Vier. Es sind Leute involviert. Zwei, drei weitere, denen ich bauen bin. Auch bei Würzburg ist das eine Reibelstadt, wo unsere erste Werkstatt entstanden ist, wo auch die ersten Fahrzeuge gebaut wurden. Deswegen, ich bin es nicht alleine, es sind schon immer noch einige Techniker dabei, die am Schrauben sind.
Okay, aber du bist so ein bisschen die treibende Kraft. Das Projekt heißt Elektronenrad, hat auch eine passende Webpräsenz unter elektronenrad.de. Was hast du denn bisher so gebaut? Also vielleicht mal zu dir, hast du irgendwie einen speziellen Hintergrund? Warst du schon immer irgendwie so ein Hardware-Schrauber?
Ja, also das Schrauben an Fahrrädern, das war schon sehr weitreichend. Ich bin auch andere Sachen gefahren. Lee Run war so eine Sache aus den 90ern. Ein Skatebike, das hat hinten einen einzelnen Reifen, der über eine Kette angetrieben wird und vorne Skateboard-Rollen. Ziemlich witzige Sache, ist auch schon.
Einen Reifen mit Kette?
In den Pedale, du trittst in kleine Pedalen rein.
Und vorne ist das einfach wie ein Skateboard-Rollen.
Ziemlich kriminelle Sache. Und da hockt man dann so wie der Affe auf dem Schleifstein und kann durch die Gegend flitzen. Außerdem bin ich begeisterter Einradfahrer seit vielen, vielen Jahren.
Stimmt, da hab ich sogar mein Video gesehen.
Da gibt's den Berg runter, die Weinberge.
Du bist ja auch so ein Privatpodcaster, der Bayerische Rindfunk.
In dem Rahmen ist das da auch passiert.
Genau, ist das schwierig?
Einradfahren, ich kann's nicht sagen. Ich hab das mit 11, 12 gelernt. Da war das halt so eine Sache.
Wie lernt man das? Da kommt so ein Clown vorbei im Dorf.
Ja, irgendwie so. Genau, da ist so ein Clown. Da stolpert man dann über die Dinger. Ja, war irgendwie das Interesse da und versucht loszulegen. Dann ist das innerhalb von einer Woche drin. Ich weiß nicht, wie das ist, wie viel der Faktor Kind und Lernen das doch noch wesentlich einfacher macht, als wenn man sich jetzt...
Aber man kommt nicht wirklich gut voran mit so einem Einrad, oder?
Nee, nicht so richtig. Also mit einem großen Rad, so 28 Zöller, da kriegt man schon ein bisschen Strecke hin. So drei Kilometer Tour, ein paar Kilometer gehen, aber dann macht es keinen Spaß. Also für Strecke ist nicht so das Richtige.
Man ist ja immer fest verbunden mit dem Rad, oder?
Das ist eine Starre-Achse, ja. Gibt es da nicht eine Lösung, wo man das so... Ich habe jetzt das allererste Mal auf einer Messe letztes Jahr eine Schaltnarbe gesehen. Da war es tatsächlich möglich, auf 1,8 zu schalten, also einen zweiten Gang direkt innerhalb einer Narbe, so eine Art Planetengetriebe zu haben. Und der Typ, der das geschraubt hat, hat sich daraus auch ein Einrad gebaut, um die Schaltung in der Narbe zu benutzen. Ich bin es auch gefahren, ein witziges Gefühl.
Da wird man schon fixer.
Ja, damit wird man schneller. Das geht auch ganz gut. Man muss ein bisschen trainieren, muss man draufkommen.
Okay, aber bei uns geht es jetzt eher um zwei oder mehr Räder. Wie viele Systeme, elektrisch betriebene Fahrräder, hast du jetzt schon geschaffen?
Also es sind jetzt auf den Straßen unterwegs, es sind acht Stück. Acht? Acht Bikes.
Die aber nicht alle dir gehören?
Nee, nicht alle meine. Nachdem ich den ersten, sozusagen den Vorreiter gemacht hatte, das erste Fahrzeug fahren hatte, und da auch schon ein paar tausend Kilometer mit abgerissen hatte und gezeigt habe, es funktioniert und das Zeug hält, sind noch ein paar andere mit eingestiegen, haben sich auch so ein Motorkit besorgt, auch so ein Bausatz, und sich daraus auch noch Elektrofahrräder geschraubt. Davon sind es vier und ich hab noch zwei Testbikes rumgerannt.
Jetzt scheint das ja schon auch schon richtiger, also das ist jetzt nicht nur so Bastlerei, sondern hast du ja schon erwähnt, es gibt fertige Kits und es gibt wohl auch schon eine bürokratische Kategorisierung elektrisch betriebener Fahrräder. Das hast du vorhin schon erwähnt, Pedelec?
Pedelec. Schöner Begriff. Pedal Electric Cycle. Pedelec, Kunstwort, baute sich so zusammen. Ist von 2002 eine EU-Richtlinie. Das kann man auch googeln. Das ist also eine EU-weite Sache. Da sind elektrisch betriebene Fahrräder mit zwei bis drei Rädern, zwei und drei Räder, darunter zusammengefasst. Und da gibt es eine bestimmte Regulierung, was die erfüllen müssen, um als solche Pedelecs fahren zu dürfen. Das Schöne daran ist, Pedelecs gelten als reguläre Fahrräder im Straßenverkehr. Das heißt also, es gibt keine Versicherungspflicht, es gibt keine Helmpflicht. Es muss nur ein ganz reguläres, wie ein straßensicheres Verkehr, sicheres Fahrrad sein, also Beleuchtung haben. Das reicht.
Also wenn es eigentlich wie ein normales Fahrrad ist, warum muss es dann überhaupt noch reguliert werden? Oder ist es nur reguliert worden, dass es nicht reguliert werden muss?
Doch, es muss was reguliert werden natürlich. Motorleistung und Geschwindigkeit. Das sind die beiden Hauptpunkte.
Ah, okay, verstehe. Nicht, dass man einfach durch die Gegend donnert.
Natürlich, wenn einer mit 45 fährt, dann ist er ein bisschen zu weit gegangen. 25 kmh ist Vmax, also die Spitzengeschwindigkeit. Kann denn das überhaupt sichergestellt werden? Ja, das ist gerade mit den digital gesteuerten Motoren, die da drin stecken, überhaupt kein Problem.
Aber man hat auch dann immer noch so eine Gänge und so.
Nein, das ist in dem Fall. Wir benutzen bürstenlose Motoren, einen Narbenmotor. Und da ist die Drehzahl relativ präzise zu bestimmen. Es gibt natürlich eine kleine Toleranz.
Also grundsätzlich, es ist erlaubt und es ist auch schon explizit geregelt. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man so ein Fahrrad hat, also wenn man sich das selber baut, heißt das, dass das dann noch abgenommen werden muss?
Nein, das ist nicht notwendig. Es geht weiter mit den Regelungen, dass das maximal 250 Watt Nennleistung haben darf. Also ein Viertel KW, um es mit den Autoleistungen zu vergleichen. Peakleistungen und Anfahrleistungen dürfen höher sein. Also das nennt sich eine Nennleistung, diese 250 Watt.
Ah, verstehe. Man darf schneller vom Fleck kommen, aber Hauptsache, man ist am Ende nicht schneller als 25 kmh.
Zumal es da noch eine schöne Lücke gibt. Bis 6 kmh ist es freigestellt. Da kann man auch mit 3 oder 4 KW anfahren, wenn man möchte. Bis 6 kmh gibt es keine Leistungsbeschränkung. Erst ab 6 bis 25.
Das heißt, man kann ordentlich Stoff geben, sozusagen.
Man kann also auch ein schweres Fahrzeug, gerade ein Lastenfahrrad, oder mal 100 kg Payloadlast mit transportieren. Dann kriegt man also eine Waschmaschine auch beschleunigt.
Da kann man auch Lautsprecher installieren, um sich dann noch so diesen Harley-Sound dazu zu klicken.
Das ist eine wichtige Sache. Ich habe das jetzt gesehen, bei Toyota gibt es schon die Personenhupe. Wenn der Prius nur noch im Elektromotor betrieb, lautlos durch die Stadt fährt, haben sie also dem Fahrrader eine Personenhupe gegeben. Nicht das normale Horn, womit man halt die Kreuzung zusammenschreit, sondern so ein Düdeln ist das. Ein digitales Düdeln wird da produziert, um Passanten, Fußgänger zu warnen.
Ein digitales Düdeln?
Ein Düdeldüdüdüdü, so ein Handy-Klingelton ähnliches Ding. Das ist die Personenhupe, das haben die Jungs drüben in der Automobilindustrie schon. Wir haben auch intensiv darüber nachgedacht, Akustik zu machen, weil es ist tatsächlich so, dass die Dinge absolut lautlos fahren. Da ist kein Getriebe, da ist keine große Drehzahl. Dementsprechend ist das Fahrgeräusch sehr, sehr leise.
Ich hätte ja schon erwartet, dass diese Elektroautos irgendwann anfangen, den Sound eines normalen Autos nachzubilden. Aber ab einer gewissen Geschwindigkeit sind es ja eigentlich ohnehin die Reifen, die laut sind.
Das ist das, was man bei höheren Geschwindigkeiten hat. Allerdings, da stört es wieder nur auf der Bundesstraße Autobahn. Die langsamen Sachen, gerade in der Stadt, im Stadtverkehr und so. Unter 50, da ist es noch nicht so laut mit den Rädern. Deswegen ist da eigentlich das Motorgeräusch immer ein wichtiger Faktor gewesen. Zumal noch dazu kommt, ein Motor brummen ist eine unheimlich tolle Sache. Du hast einen Dopplereffekt, den kennt jeder. Das kann jeder verstehen, ob dieses Auto auf einen zukommt oder nicht. Das nimmt jeder wahr. Das ist bei diesen Motorbrummen auch noch recht interessant, was jetzt komplett wegfällt.
Jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, was ist jetzt eigentlich neu? Elektromotoren sind ja nun nicht gerade eine neue Erfindung. Auch Akkus gibt es seit Ewigkeiten. Warum gab es das jetzt nicht schon vor 50 Jahren?
Genau, das sind die beiden Sachen, weswegen es das vor 50 Jahren noch nicht gab. Es ist zum einen in der Motorentwicklung sehr viel passiert. Wie ich schon erwähnt habe, es sind bürstenlose Motoren hier im Einsatz. Das heißt also, das ist nicht mehr ein klassischer Motor, wie man das aus dem Physikunterricht in der Schule kennt. Gleichstrommotor mit Bürsten drin. Die laufen dann jeweils immer eine halbe Drehung, um dann wieder die Polung zu ändern, um dann wieder die nächste halbe Drehung zu machen. Das ist das klassische Konzept. Jetzt mit den bürstenlosen ist es so, dass also nicht mehr sich die Kupferspule dreht, wie man das ja eben vom klassischen Motor kennt. Da ist eine Spule von Elektromagneten umfasst, von permanenten Magneten umfasst und die Spule rotiert. Das ist das klassische Prinzip, wie man es kennt.
Warte mal, da müssen wir glaube ich noch mal ein bisschen detaillierter einsteigen. Also ich hab mich aufgepasst in der Schule. Vielleicht fangen wir erstmal an, Elektromotor. Also wie funktioniert denn dieser klassische Elektromotor, der jetzt angeblich so ungeeignet ist? Also man hat irgendwie Strom, man hat eine Stromquelle. Also man hat ein Akku, da kommt irgendwie Saft raus, dann drücke ich auf den Knopf und dann geht dieser Strom wo rein?
In eine Spule. Diese Spule ist umgeben von permanenten Magneten und hat Bürsten dran.
Was heißt das?
Diese Spule kann sich drehen und die Bürsten sind Kontaktschleifer. Und pro halbe Drehung wird die Polung des Stroms, der durchfließt, einmal geändert, um sich wieder relativ zu der Polung von den permanenten Magneten, die man außenrum hat, eine halbe Drehung weiter abzuschließen.
Also die Magneten sind permanent im Sinne von permanent... Also dass sie permanent einen Magnetismus haben, aber sie sind auch permanent im Sinne von, dass sie fest eingebaut sind.
Und die Spule dreht sich.
Das heißt, die Rotation der Spule ist der eigentliche Motor. Das ist das Drehen der Spulen. Und dass die Spule sich dreht, das liegt daran, dass der Strom, den man dann reinschickt, gegenwirkt gegen diese Magneten. Das heißt, die Spule wird sozusagen von den Magneten gedreht.
Das löst sich ab an dem Magnetfeld.
Nach einer halben Drehung ist das vorbei.
Da muss man die Polung ändern.
Dazu ist die Spule mit Bürsten versorgt. Das heißt, mit Kontakten und die Kontakten an was?
Die schleifen auf einem Außenpol.
Also auf dem Gehäuseführer.
Die Stromzufuhr ist in der Narbe zu der Spule hin. Die Außenführung ist eben, wo der Schleifer langfährt. Dadurch wird eine Wechsel verwendet.
Das heißt, anderer Kontakt und dann wird die Stromrichtung. Verstehe, so dass sich das Ding auch weiterhin... Dadurch entsteht dann wahrscheinlich auch dieses Geräusch durch diese Wechsel.
Das Geräusch, nein, das ist eigentlich mehr die Drehzahl. Das sind jetzt hier bei diesen Motoren eben auch der Fall, dass die eine ziemlich hohe Drehzahl haben. Elektromotoren können ohne Probleme mal 10.000 Umdrehungen machen. Das kennen wir schon aus unseren Festplatten. Da wird über die hohe Drehzahl passiert das.
Das ist bei den Festplatten auch so.
Richtig.
Wir haben auch solche Bürsten.
Nein, da kommt auch die PWM-Technologie zur Stelle zu. Das ist bei Festplatten dasselbe.
Das heißt, die Festplatten sind eigentlich die Pioniere?
Das sind schon im ganz kleinen Sinne die Jungs, die die Quadrocopter bauen, unter anderem CD-ROM-Motoren. Das ist ja möglich. Das wird von Festplatten und CD-ROMs verwendet, auch die neue Technik. Die sind schon Vorreiter. Das ist richtig. Die sind die ganze Zeit um uns rum.
Was ist das eigentliche Problem bei diesen Bürsten gewesen?
Das ist ein Verschleißteil. Das muss man kontrollieren. Das ist der Hauptgrund, warum ein Elektromotor kaputt geht. Weil es mit Korrosionen und Schleifkontakten zu Problemen kommt. Betriebsstunden kannst du mitzählen und dich irgendwann darauf einstellen, die Bürsten zu tauschen.
Dann hat man gedacht, jetzt wollen wir CD-ROMs bauen und dann haben sie sich diese neue Motortechnik einfallen lassen.
Jetzt kommt auch der Mikro-Controller ins Spiel und die neuen Motorgenerationen. Da fallen immer eine Menge Begriffe. Das eine ist, sie sind bürstenlos. Sie haben keine Bürsten mehr. Sie sind sogenannte Außenläufer. Da komme ich gleich dazu, wenn ich den Aufbau beschreibe von dem Motor. Sie haben eigentlich fast keine Verschleißteile mehr. Und sie werden als Narbenmotoren verwendet, gerade in unserem Fahrradfall. Wie sieht es jetzt hier aus? Hier ist genau umgedreht das Konzept. Die Spule ist der Stator. Die Spule ist statisch montiert an einer Gabel. Steht fix da, kriegt Stromzufuhr über Kabel ganz mal in die Narbe rein. Und außen rum.
Aber es ist nach wie vor die Achse, oder?
Nein, es ist keine drehende Achse mehr.
Das heißt, die Spule umschließt die Achse?
Genau, die umschließt die Achse. Und es ist jetzt die Spule nicht mehr der Rotor, wie bei dem alten Modell, sondern der Stator, der statisch stehende Teil. Und Außenläufer, deswegen, hier sind natürlich auch permanent Magneten. Raw Earth Magnets heißen die Dinger in Englisch. Und die sind außen rum, um die Spule rum. Und die rotieren jetzt. Es ist also nicht mehr die Spule der Rotor, sondern es ist der Magnetring, der permanent Magnetring außenrum der Rotor.
Also das ist dann auch die Achse sozusagen?
Das ist das Rad. Das ist der Teil, der sich dreht. Das ist der Teil, der dann, also auch hier eingespeichert und einen Reifen bekommt, das drehende Rad ergibt.
Aber jetzt hat man ja immer noch dasselbe Problem, dass die Spule ihren Strom ändern muss sozusagen.
Genau, richtig, das ist richtig. Das passiert jetzt über den Mikrocontroller. Hier ist es so, dass ein Signal, eine Pulsweite generiert wird über einen Pulsmodulat.
Mikrocontroller, also das heißt, ein Hauptmerkmal dieser neuen Motortechnik ist, dass sie elektronisch gesteuert ist.
Genau, da kommen also noch mehr Komponenten dazu, als das jetzt gerade eben bei klassischem Motor.
Der normale Elektromotor ist halt einfach stromran.
Dank der Bürsten mit der Klack-Klack.
Vom Konstruktionsprinzip her funktioniert das einfach aus sich heraus. Aber dieses Modell, das wir jetzt beschreiben, der bürstenlosen Motoren funktioniert nur mit einem Computer. Das erklärt natürlich auch schon mal, warum das jetzt überhaupt eine neue Entwicklung ist, weil Computer gibt es zwar schon eine Weile, aber so klein und effizient zu bauen, sind sie noch lange nicht. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt eine Elektronikplatine, die gehört irgendwie noch mit dazu. Und die steuert jetzt genau was?
Das nennt sich der Controller, die Steuerplatine, das ist der Motorcontroller. Diese generiert mit einem Mikrocontroller erst mal ein Pulsignal, eine kleine, eine leichte Spannungsänderung, die diese PWM ausmacht und moduliert damit so etwas wie eine Sinuskurve.
Was heißt jetzt Pulsignal? Der Strom kommt aus dem Akku?
Mit unserem Akkustrom hat es noch gar nichts zu tun. Der Mikrocontroller gibt das nur als kleines Linesignal, wie hier am Audiokabel. Er generiert da ein Profil, wie ein Audiosignal eigentlich. Das muss man sich das vorstellen. Und diese Signalsequenz geht durch einen Verstärker.
Von was von der Frequenz reden wir jetzt hier?
Eine Sequenz meinte ich. Frequenzen ist mit der Pulsweite abhängig, geht ja nach oben. Also es hat nichts mit Wechselstrom zu tun, es ist schon noch alles gleich drum.
Ja klar, aber auch dieser Puls wird ja eine Frequenz haben?
Genau, das kann man nicht so direkt als Frequenz bezeichnen.
Also dieser Mikro-Controller erzeugt ein Signal, wo geht dieses Signal hin?
In einen Verstärker. Das ist der Punkt, wo unsere Batterie angeschlossen ist. Also es wird ein Sample generiert, wo man weiß, wie die Spulen aufgebaut sind, diesen elektrischen Fluss, dieses Magnetfeld so wandern lässt, dass es den permanenten Magnetring andrehen wird. Und dieses kleine Signal, das der Mikro-Controller generiert hat, wird durch eine Endstufe, durch einen Verstärker, wie einem Lautsprecher, mit den Fahrbatterien verstärkt und in den Motor reingeschickt. Das ist dann der Punkt, wo es eben losgeht, dass dieses Magnetfeld in dem Motor, in dem Stator, in dieser Kupfespule anfängt zu rotieren.
Das heißt, das, was vorher sozusagen die Bürste gemacht hat, indem sie an einer anderen Stelle Kontakt hatte und sich dann die Stromflussrichtung geändert hat, wird jetzt die Stromflussrichtung auch gesteuert, aber nicht durch die Bürste, sondern durch den Mikro-Controller. Und PULS heißt in dem Sinne, wir reden von einem 01-Signal, was sozusagen die Richtung angibt und entweder geht es so oder so rum.
Das PULS ist in dem PULS-Weitenmodulation, das muss ich kurz erklären, man hat ein bestimmtes Zeitfenster und es ist sozusagen die Sache, womit man auch die Geschwindigkeit reguliert von dem Motor, also wie viel Power der abkriegt. Innerhalb dieses Zeitfensters gibt man jetzt Strom an den Motor ab, an die Spule, um ein Magnetfeld dort aufzubauen. Und den Rest des Zeitfensters tut man das nicht mehr. Wenn man jetzt eben einen längeren Zeitraum innerhalb des Zeitfensters pulst, dann ist natürlich auch die Stromaufnahme im Motor höher und man wird schneller. Dadurch wird also das reguliert, dass man an eine bestimmte Geschwindigkeit kommt.
Aber dieser Strom fließt ja in die Spule. Das heißt, der Mikrocontroller versorgt diese Spule immer so mit Stoßweise mit Energie. Aber wodurch ist dann diese Richtungsumschaltung, damit das nicht mit den Magneten...
Es sind drei Phasen zueinander versetzt. Es handelt sich nicht nur um eine, wie bei dem Bürstenmotor, wo da ein Stromkreis mehr oder weniger immer wieder gedreht wird, sondern es sind drei Phasen, die da reingeführt werden.
Wo kommt dann die dritte Phase her?
Es gibt drei Zuleitungen an der Sache und die sind in einer Sternschaltung verschalten. Also es werden drei unterschiedliche Samples da eingespielt und von drei Verstärkerelementen in den Motor gespeist. Also es ist effektiv nicht nur eine Stromkreisleitung wie früher.
Also es funktioniert im Prinzip wie Drehstrom?
Das ist ein bisschen die Richtung, wobei man bestimmt schon merkt, mir fehlt die Elektrikausbildung.
Na gut, aber das ist ja beim Drehstrommotor auch so, dass er die drei Phasen nutzt und sich dadurch dreht. Und so viel Power entwickelt, und das Ganze wird hier quasi elektronisch auch nachgebildet. Und das heißt letzten Endes, die Spule wird computergesteuert so befeuert, dass sie sich optimal von diesen Magneten abstößt. Aber da ja die Spule fest ist, werden die Magneten quasi von der Spule weggedrückt und dadurch entsteht die eigentliche Rotation. Und so hat man durch das gezielte Hinzuballern von Strom eine Drehung.
Genau, und auch die Bestimmung, wie viel Leistung.
Aber ohne irgendeinen mechanischen Kontakt.
Genau, es gibt nur noch zwei Kugellager, wo das Rad dranhängt, das war's. Das hat nichts mehr mit der Elektrik zu tun. Das Ding ist für Schleistheile frei. Der permanenten Magnetring ist ein permanenter Magnetring, das ist kein Ding. Also der bewegte Teil ist komplett starr fest massiv. Da ist nichts mehr. Die Spule ist starr aufgebaut. Die ist also keine Rotationskraft ausgesetzt.
Gibt es noch weitere Vorteile, außer dass das bürstenlos ist?
Die eine Sache, die man dadurch hat, ist ein Narbenmotor, ein Hubmotor. Das ist jetzt der Vorteil, wenn es um die Lautstärke von dem ganzen Konstrukt geht, und was der Motor bei höherer Drehzahl, mit diesem Narbenmotor hat man relativ niedrige Drehzahl. Die Drehzahl entspricht ja der Drehung des Rades selber. Das ist schon die Drehzahl des Motors. Das heißt also bei einem 20 Zoll Rad, das sind so 1,20 m. Also so eine Umdrehung, um da vorwärts zu kommen, mit dem ganzen Rad entspricht eine Umdrehung des Motors. Es ist also kein Getriebe mehr, keine hohe Drehzahl involviert, die jetzt Lärm generiert oder als Schallquelle irgendwie überslegt. Sondern das Drehgeräusch ist sehr, sehr leise. Wie gesagt auch nur die Kugellager. Das macht also fast kein Geräusch. Von diesen Pulsen oder sowas hört man sowieso nichts. Das klingt komplett außen vor. Dass das irgendwie das Schlagen anfängt oder eine Vibration mit sich bringt, das ist nicht der Fall.
Und die sind wahrscheinlich auch relativ klein, diese Motoren.
Das ist jetzt eben die Frage. Will man eine Festplatte drehen oder will man Fahrrad fahren? Wenn man Fahrrad fahren will, ist das schon ein etwas größeres Teil.
Wie groß muss ich das denn vorstellen?
Die Motoren, die wir verbauen, das sind erstmal vom Gewicht her doch 5 Kilo, dass so ein Motor mit sich bringt, wo das Rad, wo man ihn einbaut, schwerer wird. Von der Größe her ist das Handteller schon größer. Was soll man da von durchmessen? 16 cm, glaube ich.
Also wie so ein kleinerer Teller zusammen.
Und der wird eben mit Speichen, man nimmt die passende Speichenlänge, dann kriegt man das dann regulär.
Das heißt, dieser Motor ersetzt die Narbe. Der Motor ist die Narbe. Und damit ist der Motor eigentlich auch optimal. Genau an der Stelle, wo die Kraft benötigt wird. Genau da drückt er sehr, er drückt sozusagen das Rad um die Mitte herum im Kreis. Und dazu braucht man natürlich dann auch noch Strom.
Richtig.
Und den kriegt man aus dem Akku. Was nimmt man da?
Wenn man da mobil sein will aus dem Akku, genau.
Du hast ja gesagt, das wäre das andere Problem. Einerseits gab es die Motoren nicht, aber auch Akkus gibt es ja schon lange.
Akkus gibt es auch schon lange, aber da ist eben das Problem mit der Kapazität. Wie viel kann man mitnehmen für wie viel Gewicht? Und im Fahrzeug ist das Wichtigste immer das Gewicht, das es hat. Da man natürlich hier auch wieder Energie braucht, um das Ganze zu bewegen. Und bei den Akkus ist es dann halt so, dass frühere Generationen, gerade wenn man jetzt an Säurebatterien denkt, die also auch noch nicht lagestabil waren, oder man musste sie lagestabil halten, durften nicht umkippen und so, was beim Fahrrad, wenn man sie in die Kurve legt, auch durfte. Und solche Sachen. Und einen heilen Gewicht eben mit an Bord hat. Das war einfach in den früheren Jahren noch zu viel. Es ist jetzt lange Zeit Bleigel das Thema gewesen. Bleigel. Bleigel-Akkus. Da ist nicht mehr, wie früher eben in einem Säurebad, was am Schwabeln, was man abdichten muss. Sondern das wird in ein Gel vergossen. Und dann kann man auch den kompletten Akku, das Gehäuse verkapseln. Die sind lagerunabhängig. Also so ein Akku kann man jetzt lagerunabhängig einfach so mit sich führen.
Aber es ist halt immer noch böses Glei drin.
Richtig, das Gewicht spricht für sich.
Schwer und giftig.
Schwer und giftig. Okay, giftig glaube ich. Das sind sie alle. Aber da ist schon immer jede Menge Chemie mit an Bord. Aber gerade das Gewicht ist eben bei den Black-Gel-Akkus doch immens. Nee, also ich fahre mit, was ich mit meinem kleinen Fahrrad dran hab, 10 Kilogramm Blei durch die Gegend. Das ist eine entsprechende...
Plus 5 Kilogramm Motor.
Das heißt, du hast so das Gewicht eines soliden, normalen Tourenfahrrads nochmal plus...
Nochmal drauf. Genau. Das ist also gerade bei den Radsportlern, die ja so mit ihrem Gramm, die jedes Gramm abzählen, ist das nicht gut zu verhandeln und dann gut drüber zu reden, wenn die die zahlen.
Radsportler brauchen auch keine Motor, sondern auch selber treten.
Also ja, das ist klar. Mit dem Gewicht braucht man da nicht zu kommen. Aber das ist so der aktuelle Stand der Dinge. Was natürlich bei den Akkus auch noch ein Faktor ist, ist die Bezahlbarkeit. Mit steht und fällt die ganze Sache natürlich immer. Und da ist es halt so, dass die Akkutechnologien die letzten Jahre noch erheblich zu teuer waren und zu viele Investitionen bedeuten.
Was kostet denn so ein Bleigel-Akku?
Bleigel, das ist noch im Rahmen. So 150 Euro kann man da schon loslegen.
Dafür gibt es dann 10 Kilo Akku.
Dafür gibt es dann 10 Kilo Akku. Das sind, um es mal konkret zu sagen, 48 Volt, mit denen wir da fahren, die Fahrspannung. Es sind also vier 12-Volt-Zellen in Reihe für 48 Volt Fahrstrom. Und Kapazität haben wir 7,2 Ampere-Stunden an Bord. Also das ist jetzt das, was in diese 10 Kilo an elektronischer Kapazität reingebracht ist.
Und wo wir gerade bei Preisen sind, was kostet so ein Motor, den du jetzt in deinem Fahrrad konkret verbaut hast?
Die Motorsätze sind eben einmal der Motor, den man sich in den Fahrradreifen einspeichern muss. Einen Controller braucht man, die Digital-Störung. Dann hat man noch ein paar andere Sachen, Gasgriff. Das sind so um die 600 Euro, die man da rechnen muss. Für das Kit, um ein normales Fahrrad umzubauen.
Plus Akku 150.
Plus Akku braucht man einen, plus 12 Volt. Oder je nachdem, ordentliche Ladegeräte sind auch nicht haushaltsüblich. Meistens muss man sich ein ordentliches Ladegerät mit reinrechnen.
Der Strom muss ja auch irgendwie rein in den Akku.
Da ist dann die Überlegung, auch Arbeitsplatz, wenn man am Pendeln ist, ist eben noch ein zweites Ladegerät vor Ort. Das man lieber nur eine Strecke Akkus an Bord hat und nicht für hin und zurück auch noch das alles mit schleppen muss. Solche Sachen spielen mit rein.
Mit anderen Worten, über kurz oder lang schmeißt man da 1000€ auf so ein Fahrrad.
Tendenz rapide fallend. Es gibt gerade aus China kommen jetzt unheimlich günstige Angebote auf Ebay und so Conversion Kids für 300€ etwa. Wobei da, also ohne Akku. Aus China. Die fahren fleißig. Da ist allerdings noch so mit der Qualität und der Haltbarkeit von den Teilen, dass es offen ist.
Aber da gibt es gerade so einen Boom.
Da ist, bei denen drüben ist es auf jeden Fall schon sehr weit verbreitet. Ich hab auch schon aus Zeitungen und so Fotos gesehen, wo man also fleißig Elektrofahrräder drauf ausmachen kann. Ein Bekannter erzählte von also recht futuristischen Szenarien in so einer riesigen Retortenstadt mit Hochhaus-Schluchten und allem lautlos rumzischende Elektrofahrräder. Jede Menge eigentlich Klarfahrrad dort als Fortbewegungsmittel. Das ist also schon so weit anscheinend. Ich hab's leider selber so noch nicht gesehen und weiß nicht viel darüber, wie es dort zustande kam und wie weit es da jetzt schon gekommen ist.
Aber dieser Bleigel-Akku, den du jetzt erwähnt hast und auch selber einsetzt, ist nicht die einzige Möglichkeit.
Genau, das ist jetzt eigentlich noch so eben ein Bauteil, das wir aus der, ich nenne es mal alten Welt benutzen. Also das sind eigentlich nicht die Akkus, die man für Fahrzeuge haben will, eben wegen des Gewichtes und wegen der eigentlich relativ niedrigen Kapazität. Da ist jetzt für die nächsten Jahre noch viel Entwicklung zu erwarten und da passiert, oder ist jetzt auch die letzten schon sehr, sehr viel passiert, neue Akkutechnologien in Richtung Lithium-Ionen, Lithium-Polymer-Akkus und es gibt mittlerweile fast zwei Dutzend junge Start-Ups und Unternehmen, die an modernen Akkutechnologien bauen. Da fallen dann oft auch Schlagworte Nanotechnologie und so. Da ist gerade unheimlich was am kochen und ich sehe es als Vorbereitung darauf, also wir fahren jetzt die Bikes, wir haben jetzt die Bikes, wir haben mit den modernen Motoren, das ist alles klasse. Die Bleigel-Akkus, die wir aktuell noch mit uns rumschleppen, rein wegen den Kostenfaktoren, die sollen raus, also die sollen abgelöst werden und das wird die Zeit möglich machen in ein, zwei Jahren. Sollte das kein Problem sein. Momentan, wenn ich jetzt einen Vergleich ziehe, ein Lithium- Polymer-Akku, gleicher Kapazität, den ich für mein Klapprad bräuchte, wäre bei über 500 Euro, das also rein noch eine finanzielle Hürde.
Okay, aber wenn man das jetzt bereit wäre auszugeben, könnte man das auch schon verwenden?
Dann ist man schon dabei und hat die gleiche Kapazität, statt 10 Kilo. Das kann man kaufen, also kein Problem, wenn man das investieren will, kriegt man die Dinger und dann hat man gleiche Situation, 48 Volt, ungefähr so viele Ampere-Stunden und halt nur noch 4, 4,5 Kilo, unter 4 Kilo.
Also wiegt die Hälfte sozusagen, bei gleicher Geschichte. Das ist ja nicht unerheblich. Genau. Aber diese anderen Verfahren erfordern ja auch ein anderes Laden, also gerade bei Lithium-Ionen, das kennt man ja vom Rechner, wenn man den falsch hält, dann geht er gleich in die Luft.
Richtig, da kommt dann also auch nochmal hinzu, dass man also auch passende Ladegeräte, die Ladeprofile nennt sich, das sind so bestimmte Phasen, Cycles, die mit dem Akku durchfahren werden in dem Ladeprozess. Und das macht also auch ein digital gestattetes Ladegerät, die besten entsprechend ein bisschen mehr als ein Bly-G-Ladegerät.
Aber diese Ladelogik ist dann sozusagen im Ladegerät und nicht im Akku selber?
Nein, in dem Fall wäre das eine Sache am Ladegerät dran.
Aber wäre es nicht eigentlich wünschenswert, dass man hinten nur noch so eine 220 Volt Schoko-Dose hinten an seinem Fahrrad dran hat?
Das ist der Plug-In. Natürlich will man den Plug dabei haben. Das ist eigentlich das Allerbeste, wenn man direkt unterwegs ist, sich an jede normale Schoko-Dose anstecken kann.
Was ist das Problem jetzt?
Man muss ein Ladegerät mitnehmen.
Das wiegt auch noch mal 5 Kilo.
Das sind Ladestationen, Tischmontage, Lüfter drin. Das Ding wiegt 3,5 Kilo.
Warum?
Das ist schon ein größeres Teil. Das sind geregelte Ladegeräte mit einer Kerntenspule drin. Nichts digital geschalten ist, wie wir es von Notebooks kennen. Weil wegen der Last, diesen 12 Ampere Ladestrom, das ist doch ein bisschen mehr, als man in einem Notebook hat. Da kommt also ein bisschen was zusammen. Ich bin am Experimentieren mit kleinen Ladegeräten unter 500 Gramm, um das eben möglich zu machen jetzt gerade.
Also du hast ja gesagt, die Fahrräder ziehen als Nennleistung so ein Viertel Kilowatt.
Genau.
Also ich bin jetzt gerade ein bisschen am Versagen, aber wie viel Strom verbraucht denn so ein Rad? Also wenn ich jetzt damit eine Stunde fahre, wie viel Kilowattstunden Strom muss ich dann vorher in den Akku da irgendwie reinballern? Also kostet das viel oder ist das irgendwie günstig?
Das ist schon sehr, sehr günstig. Wenn man das also am Schluss auf Kilometer umrechnet, Kilometer kosten, wenn man das mit Benzin vergleicht, kommt man da schon wesentlich weiter unten raus. Ich müsste kurz das Rechnen anfangen. Ich habe keine Zahlen auf dem Tisch.
Ja, wenn du das zusammengerechnet bekommst und dich da jetzt nicht vertust, dann macht das doch mal. Ich kann nebenbei noch ein bisschen senieren. Ich finde das ja ganz interessant, dass man jetzt einfach ganz normale Fahrräder nimmt und sie elektrifiziert. Es gibt ja auch schon andere populäre Geräte, allen voran natürlich, was ich auch selber ganz großartig finde, spätestens ab dem Moment, wo ich das selber mal ausprobiert habe, diesen Segway aus den USA. Ein fantastisches Gerät, wie ich finde. So ein selbstbalanciers, zweiräderiges, so eine fahrende Bushaltestelle, wo man sich einfach drauf stellt, einen Griff in der Hand hat und allein durch seine Körperbalance sagt, wohin man denn gerne fahren möchte. Leht man sich etwas nach vorne, kriegt das System das mit und fährt nach vorne und lehnt mich nicht mehr nach vorne, dann schlägt es halt auch schneller, das gleiche in die andere Richtung. Und man kann eben auch diesen Bügel nach links und nach rechts drehen und dementsprechend dann halt auch eine Drehbewegung damit reinbekommen. Und das Ganze ist irgendwie mit Accelerometern gebaut, sodass das Ding immer stabil ist.
Das Fahrzeug ist schon wirklich heiß computerisiert, da sind schon einige Schallkreise damit beschäftigt, das gerade zu halten. Die Motoren übrigens sind die gleichen. Also links und rechts in den beiden Rädern sind solche Motoren verbaut.
Das wäre nämlich jetzt mal eine Frage gewesen.
Das Begriff ist auch Schrittmotor, das ist das Ding, das kann man damit machen. Also eine konkrete Ansteuerung, in welche Richtung man mit wieviel Kraft möchte und auf welcher Radposition man sich gerade befindet. Das wird mit Sensoren festgestellt, die auch bei unseren Motoren verbaut sind.
Es gibt ja auch schon so ein paar handgemachte Segways. Ich bin da neulich erst drauf gestoßen, da fällt jetzt gerade die Quelle nicht so richtig ein. Aber an irgendeiner Uni in Europa wurde das auch mal selber gebaut.
Viele Felder, Ingenieure, die haben sich ein Einrad gebaut. Die haben nicht zwei Räder benutzt, sie haben ein fettes Rad.
Dann sind wir wieder beim Einrad.
Kippstabil schon, weil es ein unheimlich fettes Rad ist, aber genau dem Konzept mit dem Schrittmotor stabil nach oben stehend fahren zu können.
Das ist ja cool, aber so ein Segway selber zu bauen, kann ja dann so schwer eigentlich auch nicht sein, wenn man diese Motoren nimmt. Diese Motoren, so wie du sie jetzt verbaut hast, liefern die sozusagen schon diese Informationen, wo sie sich gerade befinden?
Ja, das wäre möglich. Also diese Sensoren sind auch für die Pulsweitenmodulation selber schon notwendig. Das sind Hall-Sensoren. Mit Hall-Sensoren wird das gemacht. Und die sind drin in dem Gerät, also an dem Mikrocontroller angeschlossen. Dementsprechend könnte man...
Hall-Sensoren?
Hall-Sensoren sind das.
Was für ein Hall, was sind die denn?
Hall-Sensoren, das ist notwendig, um die Drehposition zu bestimmen, die das Rad macht. Also es wird dort ein Signal, das sind drei Stück, nebeneinander verbaut. Und die geben ein Signal zurück, je nachdem, wie der Magnetring um drüber vorbeifliegt. Und daraus ist eine Positionsbestimmung möglich. Nö, das ist so ein Magnetelektronik. Ein Hall-Effekt. Hall-Effekt, das ist ein eigener.
Ich dachte schon. Das heißt, das könnte man aus diesen Motoren, mit diesen Bausätzen, diese Information auch schon gewinnen und theoretisch auch elektronisch aufgreifen?
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall schon möglich.
Also könnte man sich auch seinen eigenen Segway bauen?
Wäre dann mit diesen Motoren möglich, anzufangen zu bauen. Die Programmierung, gerade Thema Aselerometer, wow, da stelle ich mir schon ganz schön komplex vor. Da wird einiges auf einen zukommen, aber ja, es ist von der Technik her schon das richtige Teil.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich so schwer ist.
Die Frequenz ist unsere Frage.
Das ist jetzt sicherlich nicht trivial, aber du hast ja vorhin schon diese Quadrocopter erwähnt, diese mit vier Motoren ausgestatteten.
Die betreiben das, das ist effektiv auch das Prinzip.
Die arbeiten ja auch nach demselben Schema. Die haben da irgendwie ihre Beschleunigungssensoren, die können irgendwie ihre Stabilität ausgleichen. Letzten Endes macht ja ein Segway auch nichts anderes. Der merkt, er kippt und in dem Moment drückt er gegen. In dem Moment hat man halt keinen Rotor, sondern der Rotor ist dann sozusagen der Rotor in den Reifen. Man hat halt einfach die beiden Reifen und macht das.
Genau, durch sehr präzise Motoransteuerung ist das jetzt eben der neue Trick der Quadrocopter.
Willst du nicht mal sowas bauen? Das wär was.
Zwei Motoren, Google Control.
Dieser Segway, ich weiß nicht, der hat sowas ganz Adjektives. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt die Preise auch so höre, kommt mir der auch mittlerweile gar nicht mehr so teuer vor. Wo sind wir denn? 5.000, 6.000 Euro gibts das Teil schon.
Die kleinen einfachen, die kleineren für 5.000, 6.000.
Genau, dann gibt es auch diese Offroad-Variante, mit der man die Treppen auch runterfahren kann, aber nicht hoch. Kostet dann glaube ich 8.000. Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht so ganz genau, wie die Preise sind. Aber es ist alles schon so auch in so einem Bereich, wo man sich sagen kann, was ist denn jetzt so meine Computer-Lösung? Weil wenn ich jetzt gezwungen bin, wir leben jetzt in der Stadt, wir haben es einfach. Auf dem Land ist es so, dass man da eigentlich ohne Auto oder sagen wir mal zumindest ohne motorisiertes Gerät so recht nicht vorankommen kann. Dann gibt es halt irgendwie Moped, aber jeder, der bei Moped gefahren ist, weiß, Moped ist irgendwie laut und scheiße.
Genau, es geht aber ansonsten klar auf dem Land ab 15, aber auf die Moped, sonst wird es schwierig, irgendwas muss fahren.
Aber es kostet halt auch einen Höllen Geld. Moped verbraucht natürlich nicht so viel wie ein Auto, aber der ganze Sprit, das ist irgendwie alles nicht fein. Und vor allem ist es laut. Und so eine elektronische Lösung finde ich eigentlich ganz cool. Und wenn man so einen Segway hat, dann wird halt das Fahren einfach auch sehr angenehm. Das ist dann auch mal sehr speziell, wenn man einfach freisteht. Aber ich finde auch jetzt die Idee, noch mal das Fahrrad zu nehmen, finde ich natürlich geil. Wie fährt sich das eigentlich? Also wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Hat man da jetzt so eine Turbotaste und dann ist das so wie bei Zurück in die Zukunft, wo man dann irgendwie so den Fluxkompensator anschmeißt, dann macht es einfach mal duf und dann ab?
Ja genau, also so ist ein Computer dran, das heißt also man muss auf den Knopf drücken und los geht's. Also es ist so, bei meinen Modellen oder was ich jetzt gebaut habe, sind Gasgriffe dran. Man hat einen regulären Gasgriff, wie man das so vom Moped eben kennt. Rechter Hand, drehen.
Ach doch, Gas, kein Strom.
Doch, der Stromgriff heißt immer noch Gasgriff, wir hatten uns da auch schon Gedanken drüber gemacht. Also Drehschied, ein Drehgriff zur Leistungsregulierung.
Der wird wahrscheinlich auch immer so heißen.
Wir lassen den Namen, das ist doch eine schöne Erinnerung, da noch ein bisschen Gas. Und damit gibt man Gas. Das Feeling selber ist sehr erstaunlich, da man erstmal diesen unheimlich leisen Motor hat, dass da gar nichts an Geräuschen, keine Vibrationen vor allem entsteht, kein Lärm entsteht, kein Aufdröhnen, schon gar nicht, wenn man Gas gibt, losfährt. Die Beschleunigung ist unheimlich linear. Das ist ein ziemlich geiles Gefühl eigentlich. Man hat da kein Stottern oder so ein Rannenzuckel bzw. noch einen Schaltmoment, wo man auch mal so reinstockt.
Es gibt auch keinen idealen Drehbereich, sondern das Ding zieht einfach überall gleich.
Der zieht... Nee, der hat schon... Das ist schon unterschiedlich. Also es gibt schon Punkte, Leistungspunkte, das haben wir hier gerade in Kurven gesehen, wo man ausmachen kann, wo also die Effizienz und die Leistung auch am allerhöchsten ist. Das ist schon der Fall. Aber von der Beschleunigung her ist es halt sehr homogen. Es stört nichts rein. Es ist also ein sehr interessantes Gefühl, da mit rumzudüsen.
Das heißt, du sitzt auf deinem Fahrrad und ziehst wie am Moped einfach an dem Gasgriff und damit führst du mehr oder weniger Power rein.
Nicht ganz, nicht ganz. Da haben wir auch vorhin bei den Pedelecs und der EU-Regelung noch eins ausgelassen. Ein Ding, was auch zu dieser Regulierung gehört und ganz wichtig ist. ZB der springende Punkt, weswegen es das Pedelec gibt. Ein Tret-Sensor. Es muss an diesen Fahrzeugen, um diese Richtlinie zu entsprechen, ein Tret-Sensor verbaut sein.
Das heißt?
Tret-Sensor kann man sich so vorstellen. Der ist da, wo getreten wird, nämlich in einem Pedalen dran. Also da, wo man seine Pedale dran hat. Das bedingt oder das included, dass das Fahrrad Pedalen hat. Also eben kein Mofa ist oder kein Roller ist. Sondern man da reinpedaliert. Dieser Sensor nimmt wahr, dass man eine Drehung produziert. Er kontrolliert auf die Richtung. Rückwärts treten zählt nicht. Dieser Sensor ist notwendig, um das Gas frei zu geben. Um das Gas überhaupt möglich zu machen.
Das heißt, man hat sein normales Fahrrad, normale Pedale und Kette und alles?
Genau, da wird so ein kleiner Sensor hingebaut.
Das heißt, diese Räder fahren auch ohne Strom?
Richtig, natürlich.
Fahren die dann schlechter?
Wenn man noch den Akku zu Hause lässt, hat man es also wirklich nur noch mit diesem 5 kg Motor da vorne zu tun. Aber das ist eigentlich okay.
Der ist vorne der Motor?
Wir haben jetzt die größtenteils Vorderrad verbaut. Das muss man aber nicht. Hinterrad geht auch mit Ritzeln, ganz normal mit einer Schaltung. Deinen Kettenschaltung kann man dann auch hinten reinbauen.
Na ja, aber normalerweise vorne.
Normalerweise ist es wegen den Akkus vorne der Motor und hinten irgendwo die Akkus hinpacken wegen der Gewichtsverteilung. Macht das deswegen am meisten Sinn. Da kommt es her.
Man könnte ja auch den Akku nach vorne packen.
Ja, das wäre dann die andere Sache.
Gibt es da jetzt einen Vorteil darin, dass man sich vorne ziehen lässt und nicht hinten schieben lässt?
Nee, das ist nicht so. Die Bedingungen, dass man bei Eis nicht mehr loskommt, das sind da andere. Das ist kein besonders großer Faktor. Es ist schon vom Fahrgefühl her ein Unterschied. Mit einem Hinterradantrieb kommt das, ich weiß nicht, wie man das nennt, spritziger, dieses Mofa-Feeling. In dem Vorderrad ist das schon sehr relaxed, weil man da einfach angezogen wird. Man merkt schon einen Unterschied in den beiden Arten, wie der Motor verbaut ist.
Wie findest du das Vorderrad besser?
Für zwei Räder ist das Konzept der Wahl, dass man vorne den Motor reinbaut, den auch auf der Lenkung hat. Das ist bisher auch das Rad, womit man lenkt. Und die Akkus hinten irgendwo verbaut. Das umgedrehte Konzept wäre dann, die Akkus entweder in den Trapezrahmen mittig, vorne auf den Lenker will man die sich nicht packen. Das macht keinen Sinn, das Gewicht da oben vorne hinzumachen. Deswegen ist das bei zwei Rädern immer die Überlegung mit der Gewichtsverteilung, und die ist eigentlich die effektivste. Und es kommt hinzu, die Motoren sind ein bisschen billiger für Vorderrad, da ist das einfach eine 10 cm Gabel und gut. Für Hinterrad braucht man mit dieser Ritzeladapter und einer asymmetrischen Einspeichung, die Achse ist breiter. Das wird teurer, deswegen ist ein Vorderradmotor in dem Fall einfacher zu bauen und nicht noch an dem Kettensystem verbaut.
Geht das jetzt auch so weiter wie beim Auto, dass man jetzt noch ABS und Anti-Schlupf-Regelung da irgendwie?
Vielleicht bei den drei Rädern. Also bei den Motorrädern ist mittlerweile ja auch ABS regulär. Da haben wir noch nichts. Also ich bau zwar viele Bremsen möglichst auf Hydraulik um, aber die sind leider noch mechanisch stark.
Gute Bremsen sind natürlich angesagt, wenn man so viel mit sich rumschleppt.
Also das ist das, was ich eigentlich allen empfehle und auch mit jedem der Bikes gemacht habe. Nach dem Umbau den Motorkit ran und mit dem Umbau von dem Motorkit auch noch Bremsen umbauen. Neue Bremsen, bessere Bremsen. Was für Bremsen nimmt man dann? Wenn da noch so alte Klammerbremsen dran sind, dann am besten V-Breaks, was im Fahrradladen normal zu kriegen ist. V-Breaks sind wie so ein V, zwei solche Arme, die es zusammentrückt. Früher war das so eine Kralle, so eine Klammer. Wenn dann die V-Breaks oder in Richtung Scheibenbremsen. Das ist natürlich das Beste, was man machen kann. Gerade bei kleineren Rädern eine Scheibenbremse.
Das geht auch noch zusammen mit dem Narbenmotor.
Ja, das ist okay.
Und dass man so eine Bremse auch direkt mit in den Motor. Ich meine, so ein Motor müsste doch auch aus sich heraus bremsen können.
Genau, da sind wir wieder bei einem ganz eigenständigen Punkt und einem Thema, mit dem Motor wieder bremsen. Das würde ja bedeuten, auch wieder Strom zurück zu speisen. Das ist nicht so ganz das wahre bis zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt. Dafür gibt es mehrere Gründe. Das eine und der wichtigste ist eigentlich gerade mit dem Fahrrad. Man hat zu oft die Situation, wo man jetzt stehen bleiben will. Man muss jetzt in die Bremse gehen und hat da nicht groß Zeit, das über eine Motorsteuerung, was eben möglich wäre, abzubremsen. Man möchte wirklich eine abrupte, starke Bremsungsmöglichkeit haben. Das ist mit dem Motor nicht so einfach. Vor allem die Rückspeisung ist dann ausgeschlossen. Man bräuchte ziemlich große Elemente in dieser Verstärkerschaltung, um das möglich zu machen. Das würde teurer werden. Eine Rückspeise-Elektronik, also eine Elektronik, die in der Lage wäre, Bremskraft, die eingespeist wird in den Motor, auch noch in die Batterien zurückzuladen, würde noch mal erheblich Kosten produzieren und ist bis jetzt auch noch nicht so wirklich zu haben. Es gibt schon einige Modelle, die das machen.
Aber unabhängig von dieser möglichen oder nicht möglichen Stromgewinnung, könnte nicht dieser Motor selbst auch sehr gut bremsen?
Ja, aber wie gesagt, man müsste...
Genau das Gegenteil tut, von dem, was er normalerweise tut, also einfach in die andere Richtung beschleunigt, wie das ein Flugzeug macht, wenn es landet?
Nee, eine Schubumkehr wäre es nicht. Man würde das allerdings mit größeren Bauteilen in der Verstärkerschaltung machen müssen. Aber möglich wäre es ja.
Und dann möchte man es wahrscheinlich auch wieder auf dem Hinterrand haben, weil sonst fliegt man einfach nach vorne. Aber sowas gibt es jetzt noch nicht.
Sowas ist noch nicht, nee. Wäre aber auf jeden Fall möglich. Eine unheimlich gute Bremse ist es schon, also das ist richtig. Es gibt die Überlegung, eine Wegfahrsperre zu machen. Wenn man den Motor im Stand kurz schließt, kann man ihn nicht mehr schieben, es geht nicht, ist klar. Man würde ja so viel Strom erzeugen, wie man Kraft reinsteckt und die gegen die Magneten schieben.
Der Sequoie hat das ja auch, ne?
Der hat eine Wegfahrsperre, der lockt die. Genau, das müsste das Konzept sein.
Ja, die haben so einen kleinen Chip obendrauf und wenn man den halt wegnimmt, das ist wie so ein Fahrzeugschlüssel, dann ist das Ding einfach nur schwer und steht rum.
Genau, dann lockt der.
Der ist schwer mit den Akkus. Ich weiß nicht, was der nominell wiegt, aber so 30 Kilo wird er bestimmt zusammenkriegen mit zwei Motoren.
Letzter Stand war auch, sie haben Nickel-Metallhydrat-Akkus drin, das ist auch noch ziemlich gewichtig. Jetzt wahrscheinlich Polymer oder Lithium. Aber Gewicht, Gesamtgewicht habe ich nicht im Kopf. Aber schon einiges, es kommt schon immer ein bisschen was zusammen.
Hast du jetzt eigentlich irgendwas ausgerechnet, mit dem tatsächlichen Stromverbrauch?
Ja, was ich an Bord habe, war interessant. Und zwar ist es so, dass ich mit dem erwähnten Setup, diese 48 Volt und 7,2 Ampere-Stunde, ich habe 345 Wattstunde an Bord, also 0,34 Kilowattstunde habe ich da.
Und damit kannst du wie lange fahren?
Das sind, sagen wir jetzt mal, 25 Kilometer, kommt auf die Temperaturen an, kommt unheimlich darauf an, wie man fährt. Da ist es also ein ganz großer Faktor, auch in der...
25 Kilometer Reichweite.
0,33 rechnet sich leichter. Also mit einer Kilowattstunde Kapazität an Bord wären wir bei unseren 100 Kilometern, nicht richtig?
Ne, mal 375 Kilometer. Okay, eine Kilowattstunde für 75, also 1,3 irgendwie für... Das heißt, wenn man jetzt mal rechnet, eine Kilowattstunde kostet einen irgendwie 20 Cent. Das heißt, so für 25 Cent...
Ja, man hat noch das Ladegerät. Da sind einige Verluste im Ladeprozess doch noch mit drin. Dann kann man schon das doppelte rechnen. Aber macht es nicht schlimmer. Also um hier diese 350 Wattstunde reinzubekommen, braucht man schon fast 700 was an Verschleiß und mit dem Ladegerät drauf geht.
Das ist im Vergleich zum Auto doch schon immer noch deutlich billiger. Gut Faktor 10 gespart. Ich weiß nicht, wie das mit dem Wirkungsgrad wird.
Der ist auf jeden Fall besser als bei dem Benzinbetrieb.
Ich meine, sind die Motoren so, dass sie sich jetzt noch befindet sich das gerade so in einer Verbesserungswelle oder ist das jetzt erstmal das, was man so hat?
Das ist jetzt erstmal der Stand. Ich wüsste nicht, wie da die Entwicklung wäre. Natürlich bessere Leiter in den Spulen wären Optionen. Bessere Magneten, Permanentmagneten.
Leichtere Akkus natürlich, dass man nicht so viel rumfahren muss.
Vielleicht die 10 Kilo sparen ist natürlich das Einfachste.
Oder einfach weniger Essen.
Man will ja noch strampeln, da braucht man Kraft für.
Na gut, aber wenn ich 10 Kilo abnehme, dann hab ich mein Akku schon wieder raus. Du bist ja ein Leichtgewicht.
Ich fahr hier mit einem gewissen Vorteil, ich kann die Akkus einfach so draufschlagen. Wenn ich jetzt für andere Leute rechnen muss mit regulären 80 Kilo oder so, dann ist schon...
Auweia, und ich muss schon zu Lithium-Ionen-Akkus greifen. Okay, also mit anderen Worten, das ist alles nicht teuer im Betrieb, aber es ist nicht ganz billig in der Herstellung. Wo kriegt man denn jetzt so ein Zeug her? Also was sind denn so die Quellen für diese Technik? Wie hast du gesagt, gibt es in China, gibt es aber auch hier? Was verbaut ihr denn da in euren Farben?
Also was wir verbauen ist Crystallight, ein Hersteller aus Kanada. Was heißt ein Hersteller? Designer ist in Kanada, die konstruieren das Zeug in einer kanadischen Firma. Und Produktion ist natürlich in China. Die haben Serien, unterschiedliche Größen, unterschiedliche Leistungsklassen auch. Gerade in Kanada darf man noch ein bisschen mehr machen mit den Elektromotoren als unsere EU-Regelung hier. Das geht also auch, leistungsstärkere Motoren haben die im Angebot. Das geht über einen Importeur, der die tatsächlich selber per Luftfracht hier so dutzendweise einfliegt. Da gibt es noch keine großen Handelsketten, da gibt es noch keine Großhändler. In dem Sinne für die auch auf Lager haben. Die Jungs, die die Teile auf Ebay anbieten, wird genauso laufen. Schiffscontainer, ich weiß nicht, was der da eingekauft hat. Aber auch kleine Einzelpersonen, keine Konsortien, keine Firmen, die da dranstehen und da größeren Import betreiben. Was man bekommt im Fahrradladen, auch zu sehen, oft genug sind Komplettlösungen, auch Giant, eine der größten Fahrradhersteller überhaupt, hat reguläre, voll ausgebaute Fahrzeuge im Angebot. Elektrofahrzeuge mit Akku, mit dieser Motortechnik.
Das heißt, da entsteht jetzt auch langsam ein Markt, weil die Fertigungskosten einfach so sinken, dass es mittlerweile als Produkt interessant wird.
Noch ziemlich teuer, diese Fahrräder, das sind zu 1500 Euro aufwärts, aber gerne auch bei manchen Modellen, gerade jetzt, wenn neue Lithium-Ionen drin sind, 2.500 Euro, kann man da schon ausgeben. Da sind allerdings die Vorteile, dass es recht elegant verbaut ist, dass die es komplett in das Fahrzeug integriert haben. Das heißt, auch der Akku ist sehr gut gelöst, entweder im Gepäckträger oder im Rahmen verschwindet. Und dort klickbar, mit so einem schönen Klicksystem, das auch ordentlich austauschbar ist. Das sind also so Vorteile, die man in so einer Komplexlösung hat, aber auch erst mal noch bezahlt, weil einen Massenverkauf gibt es davon auch noch nicht so richtig.
Was mir auch noch über den Weg gelaufen ist, ist so ein System, jetzt wo wir gerade über diesen fertig verkauften Lösungen wieder angelangt sind. Easyglider ist glaube ich aus der Schweiz. Gibt es auch noch nicht so lange, das ist dir bekannt, ne?
Jo, schönes Teil. Ich würde gern mal, habe ich nur gehört von. Und das Bild gesehen, ich bin es noch nicht gefahren leider.
Also das ist überhaupt gar kein komplettes Fahrrad, sondern das ist eigentlich nur dieser Motor mit einem Reifen drum herum. Mit einer langen Stange dran nach oben, die einmal sich so abknickt, die hat man dann einfach so in der Hand.
Wie ein Lenker, genau.
Genau, aber mehr so ein L, also es geht so an die Seite und dann geht das Ding einmal kurz quer, da greift man das dann. Und unten ist halt nur der Motor und der Reifen. Ja, und dann kann man sich seine Inlineskates anziehen und sich dadurch einfach ziehen lassen.
Richtig.
Womit man natürlich überhaupt keinen Rahmen und sonstige Sachen mit sich mitführt, die noch irgendwie schwer wären. Optional kann man unten aber auch noch eine Stange anbringen mit so einer Art Surfbrett, wo man sich dann einfach drauf stellen kann. Dann hat das schon wieder so ein bisschen Segway-Style. Da lässt man sich einfach von diesem Teil durch die Gegend ziehen. Hast du die schon mal live gesehen oder kennst du die auch nur aus dem Web?
Das kenne ich auch nur von den Bildern live gesehen. Nichts. Ich kenne auch nur die Promo-Bilder eben mit Inlinern dran beziehungsweise als Roller oder mit einem Rollbrett.
Sieht total schick aus. Also auch wenn man sich hier so die Videos im Web anschaut. Ich meine, da kann man jetzt mutmaßen, dass sich das hier wahrscheinlich einfach auch um dieselbe Technik handelt. Das ist jetzt einfach das, womit das gebaut wird, also auch diese modernen Motoren. Und damit wir dann irgendwie durch die Gegend gefahren.
Und auch hier, gerade bei der Baugröße, wo sie das wirklich alles in diesem Radrahmen, wie auch immer man das nennen will, wo auch der Motor drin steckt, die Akkutechnik natürlich, die dort verbaut ist.
Sehr schick hier. Easy-Glider. Tralla, da gibt es dann auch noch für Kinder ein Groß und ein Klein. Also es tut sich da einfach ein komplett neuer Markt auf. Aber vor allem ist es halt einfach auch ein schöner Hacksport, oder? Was würdest du jetzt Leuten empfehlen, die vielleicht Bock haben, sich ihr Rad zu elektrifizieren oder sich vielleicht sogar auch ein neues Rad zulegen, was, sagen wir nochmal angenommen, ich würde jetzt ein Rad explizit für den Elektro-Einsatz dann auch konzipieren. Würde ich dann irgendwann irgendwas anders machen? Würden wir dann vielleicht gleich so ein Dreirad bauen oder so?
Das nicht unbedingt. Das klassische Zweiradfahrrad ist doch das Design, das jetzt 100 Jahre sauber durchgehalten hat, sich nicht verändert hat, wenn man es mal so betrachtet. Und auch wirklich das Beste ist, ich hab so ein Dreirad, ich fahre auch Liegereider, schon ein paar Sachen. Nee, es ist diese alte Drahtesel tatsächlich wirklich und das Design eigentlich, das man haben will.
Okay, das heißt, man kauft sich das dann so aus Komponenten zusammen?
Ist genau auch eben eine Preisfrage das Allereinfachste. Es ist natürlich schon eine gewisse Materialbelastung da durch die Motorisierung, durch zusätzliches Gewicht. Sodass man also schon auch auf etwas qualitativere Sachen zurückgreifen möchte, nicht das Baumarkt-Fahrrad für unter 200 Euro umbauen. Das lohnt sich nicht, wird man Verschleißteile zu viele von haben, Stückchenweise das alles tauschen, weil es unter dem Motorbetrieb doch schon mehr Belastung ausgesetzt ist.
Weil es einfach mehr Gewicht hat?
Mehr Gewicht, mehr Potenzial an Bordsteinkanten ordentlich zu schrubben.
Aber man möchte auf jeden Fall so bauen, dass man jetzt auch gleich für so kritische Komponenten wie zum Beispiel den Akku dann auch die passenden Halterungen hat.
Genau, das ist also eine Sache Gepäckträger. Da gibt es Lösungen, stabilere, ausgebaute Träger als den Standard, den man normalerweise mit ranbekommt, wo diese niedliche kleine Federbügel mit dran ist. Das kriegt man im regulären Fahrrad-Fahrhandelfach-Betrieb auch schon so fertig an Fahrrädern dran. Da gibt es verstärkte Gepäckträger. Da kann man sagen, ok, ich habe hier 25 Kilo, ich gebe mir noch ein bisschen mehr an. Reguläre Tragetaschen und so. Da ist einiges auf dem Markt. Da gibt es unheimlich viel aus dem Touring-Trekking-Ding. Das heißt, da kann man sich regulär bedienen. Das sind Sachen, die man beachtet, eben die Bremsen beachten, was man für ein Modell man da nimmt. Genau, also das sind so ein paar Sachen. Aber mehr Kriterien sind das eigentlich nicht.
Dann brauchen wir einen Motor.
Die Standards, genau. Der Motor kommt im Vorderrad in eine 100 mm Gabel. Das ist Standard, da findet man fast nichts anderes mehr. Ist auch eine Federgabel gerade.
Aber ist das jetzt eigentlich zulässig, nach dieser Pedelec-Verordnung, dass ich jetzt einfach nur einen Motor habe und eine Drucktasse und nicht drück drauf?
Du darfst das ohne diesen Tret-Sensor. Nee, doch, den musst du haben. Genau, das ist der sprengende Punkt für das Pedelec. Und das darfst du dann aber auch privat selber für dich bauen mit so einem Konverter-Kit.
Also das hat dein Rad.
Genau.
Dein Rad hat so einen Tret-Sensor. Das heißt, wenn du nicht gleichzeitig auch trittst, dann kriegst du auch keinen Strom auf dem Motor.
Da kann ich nicht Gas geben, kann ich da drehen so viel. Ich will das mit nichts passieren.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo du auch nur die Füße stillhältst...
Genau, hört der Motor, geht die Leistung aus.
Das ist sozusagen auch wahrscheinlich deshalb gemacht worden, damit es einfach so vom User-Interface genauso ist wie ein Fahrrad. Ich höre auf zu treten. Also gibt es nicht, dass man in dieser Situation ist, oh Gott, welchen Knopf soll ich drücken? Mama, Hilfe...
Genau. Das ist also das Konzept und das ist auch der Hintergrund, weswegen diese Pedelec-Sache so funktioniert hat.
Diesen Tret-Sensor, den gibt es dann gleich mit dem Motor dazu? Oder ist das nochmal eine eigene Geschichte?
Nein, keine eigene Geschichte. Das wird an den Controller angeschlossen, das wird von dem Motorkontroller geregelt und mit wahrgenommen, da geht ja auch der Gasgriff rein.
Aber wo wird denn dieser Sensor dann angebracht?
An den Pedalen, unten an dem Tretlager. Also da, wo die Pedale sind.
Und der misst dann genau was?
Nur, dass du eine Drehung hast. Das ist wie ein Tacho, wenn man das mit Magnet-Tacho kennt. Da rotiert so ein kleiner Magnet an einem Sensor vorbei.
Kein Axelorometer oder so?
Sie haben einen kleinen Trick drin, um die Richtung festzustellen, nicht, dass du rückwärts trittst und Gas gibst. Das war so das einzigste, was da spannend ist.
Da könnte man die Schubumkehr einschalten, die ich vorhin schon angesprochen habe.
Also das geht ja nur bei Kettenschaltung. Also der ist richtungsbasiert.
Ich bin verschnupft. Der Winter fordert sein Tribut. Dabei bin ich noch nicht mal mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs. Vielleicht auch gerade deswegen, weil man muss ja eigentlich ein bisschen mehr raus. Find ich auch super. Für Hacker ist das ja eigentlich mal ein schöner Grund, ein bisschen in die körperlichen Betätigungen zu gehen, wenn gleich dann auch Strom unterstürzt. Fährst du denn eigentlich dann nur auf Strom oder fügst du auch noch Energie hinzu?
Ja, ich tret schon mit dazu. Das lohnt sich unheimlich. Was Reichweite und Akkubelastung betrifft, vor allem beim Anfahren. Man kann da unheimlich Kilometer am Ende und der Gesamtstrecke rausholen. Wenn man beim Anfahren selber tritt, da hat man einen passenden Hebel mit den Beinen und Pedalen. Das ist klasse eigentlich, dass man da zweimal kräftig in die Pedale tritt, dann rollt das Teil und erst dann mit dem Motor voll Gas gibt, nicht den Motor einen da komplett von Null hochziehen lässt.
Weil das kostet viel Energie. Ah, verstehe. Und im reinen Fahren, was ist jetzt sozusagen der eigentliche Komfort, den du gewinnst? Also lässt du dich dann einfach ziehen und trittst so ein bisschen mit?
Ich dreh so ein bisschen mit, genau.
Und genießt, dass du nicht so viel Energie aufbringen musst? Oder fährst du schneller als sonst oder beides?
Nee, also es ist schon die Sache, dass man eben schon noch mit dazu tritt, weil es zum Vorteil ist mit dem Akkusparen. Und es ist auch cool daran, dass man sich aber nicht zu überanstrengt, bzw. man hält automatisch das, was einem da gerade Spaß macht, sozusagen. Also fahren tut das Ganze eh. Wie viel man jetzt noch dazu reintritt, ist dann eben eine Sache auch von, wie es sich gerade anfühlt, wie viel man gerade Bock hat. Und verhindert halt, dass man da den Schweißausbruch einsteuert oder so. Die Controller kann man auch mit ein bisschen mehr Volt betreiben. Und dann ist das auch schon der Hebel, um da mehr Geschwindigkeit rauszuholen.
Den Computer mit mehr Volt betreiben?
Den Verstärker. Also das Fahrrad, den Verstärker statt mit jetzt hier in dem Beispiel 48 Volt, kann man ihn auch mit 60 oder 72 befeuern. Kühlrippen nicht vergessen, wie am Computer. Aber dann kann man auch natürlich höhere Leistungen erzielen. Also das ist kein Problem.
Führe. Das heißt, ah, das heißt, dann kann man auch, siehst du, so einen Turbo-Aufsatz, irgendwie vorne so ein Horn reinmachen.
Genau, gleich Fahrtwinkel kühlt, weil mein Controller wird heiß. Also das ist kein Problem. Offroad haben wir auch mit Tests für 40, 45 kmh ohne Probleme hingekriegt.
Und diese flachen Fahrräder, Liegeräder, haben die nicht einen aerodynamischen Vorteil?
Also das ist schon, gerade wenn man mal ein bisschen Gegenwind abbekommt auf einem normalen Fahrrad, schon ein unheimlicher Faktor, was man mit dem Liegerad mit dem Fahrrad macht.
Spart das da nicht auch eine Menge Strom?
Das ist nicht so relevant. Ja, am Schluss, ich weiß nicht, so viel gerechnet an der Stelle habe ich nicht. Man leidet auf jeden Fall nicht mehr so sehr drunter, dank dem Elektrofahrrad eh der Fall, dass der Gegenwind nicht mehr stoppt. Aber ja, in der Gesamtkilometerzahl wird es einfließen. Also dann wird schon auch noch mehr Distanz möglich sein. Wobei das für Zweiradriegeliegereider gelten würde. Meines, was man hier auch auf der Webseite sieht, das Dreiradriegel ist da komplett aus dem Rennen, weil man vorne zwei parallele nebeneinander stehende Räder hat. Da ist eine Achse und da treten Scherkräfte auf. Das kostet unheimlich Kraft.
Wie beim Dreiradriegel hast du vorne zwei Räder?
Genau, beim Dreirad, das Liegerad, sind vorne zwei Räder, hinten eins. Ach, da gibt es auch andersrum. Da hat man aber bei beiden die Situation, dass man eine Achse hat, wo zwei Räder links und rechts montiert sind, parallel nebeneinander. Dort entsteht ein drittes Radreibung. Das ist das eine, was es schwerer macht. Nur zwei Räder, die hintereinander herfließen. Sondern man hat jetzt zwei Räder nebeneinander und da hat man Querkräfte. Die laufen ja immer ein bisschen aufeinander zu oder auseinander. Oder haben so einen gewissen Sturz zueinander. Man kann sich auch nicht mehr in die Kurve legen. Das ist gelaufen. Das ist dann wie Motorrad mit Beiwagen, falls man das kennt. Das ist eine spezielle Fahrart, die Situationen hat, dass man aus der Kurve plötzlich rauslenkt.
Man könnte aber dann auch hergehen und hinten die beiden Räder jeweils mit Motor ausstatten und vielleicht auch noch diese Laufdifferenz dann auch elektronisch versuchen, rauszurechnen.
Klar, gerade mit der Motorleistung spielt es ja keine Rolle. Wenn wir ein Auto kennen, dann machen wir es ja nie anders.
Was denn, Herr Wachtmeister, 50 Stundenkilometer? Ich hab ja auch zwei.
Tandem. Eine sie, eine ich, und dann dürfen wir 50 fahren.
Könnte richtig Power machen.
Also gerade, wenn wir einen Offroad-Test gemacht haben, wo wir so von ausgehen, dass wir über einen Kilowatt gekommen sind, auch an Motorleistung, das ist schon eine ganz andere Welt. Nicht zu vergleichen mit was man vom Auto kennt, da will man ja eigentlich 70, 80 und 100 Kilowatt haben, aber das ist schon ein unheimlichen Zug. Also das ist schon nochmal ein anderes Feeling und andere Effekte.
Was habt ihr denn da so offroad getestet?
Ja, das ist einmal das Dreirad, mit reiner Akku-Power gute 45 km.
Also wie offroad war das jetzt?
Nicht im STVO, schon auf einem ordentlichen Grund, geteerte Situation, aber nicht im STVO-Betriebbereich.
Achso, aber jetzt nicht so eine Motorrad-Teststrecke?
Wo es halt geht.
Wie lange hält denn so ein Apparat, wenn man ihn jetzt nicht zu sehr durch die Teststrecken jagt? Also wie lange hält so ein Akku, wie lange hält so ein Motor?
Du meinst also die Lebensdauer? Genau, bei dem Motor eben, was wir vorhin schon hatten, ist durch die beiden Kugellager, die die einzigste Reibung sind, sehr niedrig und das Kugellager lässt sich auch günstig einfach tauschen. Das kann man auch selber machen, das funktioniert sehr gut mit dem.
Also ist nicht verschleißfrei, aber so verschleißarm, der wird einen lange begleiten.
Zwei relativ günstige Kugellager, genau.
Das heißt, was kaputt geht, ist der Akku?
Was kaputt geht, ist eventuell der Controller. Da ist diese Verstärker-Endstufe, da sind Mosfets drin, das was das Ding auch ziemlich teuer macht. Und dass man da Probleme mit hat, da habe ich auch schon die ein oder andere Leiche rumliegen, dass uns mein Controller abgebrannt ist. Das heißt, durch die Offroad-Tests, wo wir uns ein bisschen viel Leistung abgekriegt haben, ein bisschen heiß geworden sind. Der andere war Wasser-Einbruch, da kann man natürlich auch nicht helfen, wenn das Ding unter Wasser setzt.
Aber der Motor selber nimmt dadurch keinen Schaden?
Nein, das ist nicht drin. Dass da jetzt irgendwie durch eine Kurzschlusssituation der Motor durchglüht, das wird nicht passieren. Das wird irgendwie für andere Sachen eher schiefgehen.
Und außer diesem Crystallite, die ihr jetzt verwendet, gibt es da noch andere Hersteller, die da jetzt erwähnungs-, also hast du noch andere Erfahrungen gesammelt?
Ja, es gibt einen deutschen Hersteller, Heinzmann heißen die. Die sind von der Preislage her auch noch mal ein ganzes Stück höher. Da wird es auch noch mal wesentlich teurer. Die kommen aus der Rollstuhl- und Behindertenbeförderung-Ecke, Sonderfahrzeuge.
Rollstühle, die haben natürlich... Diese Motoren kommen wahrscheinlich auch bei Rollstühlen mittlerweile durch uns im Einsatz.
Ja, das ist bei Heinzmann der Fall, weil die Firma kommt da aus der Medie-Ecke, um so Zeug zu machen. Die bauen das dann halt als Fahrrad.
Dürfen die dann auch 25 Stundenkilometer fahren?
Nee, ich kenne mich nicht ganz so mit aus, was bei diesen Fahrstühlen ist.
Ich bin noch nicht vom Rollstuhl überholt worden auf der Straße.
Die haben hinten mal so ein 6 kmh-Aufkleber, mal gar nichts. 20 ohne Treten geht auch.
Treten tut der Herr 2020 nicht.
Tarnung, ich sag dir, das ist alles Tarnung.
Sobald die Dunkelheit kommt, zieht er ab. Und die haben zwei.
Die können dann gleich das Lenken auch miterlegen.
Daumensteuerung, Joysticksteuerung. Na ja, da haben wir ja neue olympische Disziplinen.
Stopp, du hattest gerade noch den Akku. Der geht kaputt, das ist richtig. Das ist auch der größte Punkt eigentlich, was man auf jeden Fall mit reinrechnen muss. Gerade wenn man schon hört, im Lithium-Ionen-Bereich 4-500 Euro für einen Akku ausgeben, der wird nicht ewig halten. Das ist ein Verschleißteil, den kannst du auch gleich auf die Kilometer mit draufschlagen. Da muss man also vorher mit Erfahrungswerten am besten umgehen bzw. im Nachhinein sich nachrechnen, wo man gelandet ist, wie weit es gereicht hat. So ein Akku hat eine begrenzte Ladezyklenzahl, die er mitmacht. Er wird dann auch nicht abrupt sterben, sondern natürlich, wie man es von Notebook und allem anderen auch kennt, sukzessive seine Kapazitätenmöglichkeiten verlieren. Das sind Sachen, die hier komplett mit reinspielen und dann gerade bei den teuren Akkus auch relevant sind im Gesamtkilometerpreis, was man dann am Schluss gebraucht hat. Das ist auch immer so ein bisschen abschreckend, so wie bei den Beamern. Wie 300 Euro Ersatzbirne. So ungefähr, wie Akkuersatz. Irgendwann wird es nötig.
Ja, spannendes Thema. Haben wir denn jetzt irgendwas vergessen? Ich hab so den Eindruck, wir haben es jetzt schon ganz gut zusammengekramt. Das war vollständig. Was ist so das nächste Forschungsfeld?
Ja, die neuen Akkus.
Außer der Schubumkehr, neuen Akkus und den Turbolader.
Das Forschungsfeld wird jetzt auf jeden Fall viel, viel in die Akku-Richtung gehen. Ansonsten bleiben wir bei dem, was wir jetzt ganz gut umgesetzt haben.
Was muss denn passieren, bis man die 220 Volt-Stickdose hat? Würdest du das dann erwägen, zu sagen, die drei Kilo Scheiß drauf, die schleppe ich jetzt mit, weil die habe ich mir durch den Akku gespart. Dafür kann ich einfach überall Strom.
Das wird eine Schrittrichtung sein, dass wenn man anfängt, die Kilogramm bei dem Akku zu sparen, dass man die dann auch wieder für ein Ladegerät verwenden kann. Ich habe jetzt auch schon ein kleines dabei, das ist noch nicht so effizient, das ist noch nicht so richtig.
Lithium-Eon hat ja auch den Vorteil, dass man jederzeit laden kann. Dass man nicht so diesen Memory-Effekt hat, wie bei Metallhydrate ist das noch der Fall. Das ist am besten, wenn die so richtig leer sind. Und bei Lithium-Eon, die fühlen sich eigentlich immer am besten, wenn sie sowieso in der Mitte immer die ganze Zeit hin und her gehalten werden.
Bewegt werden, genau. Das heißt also, das ist okay. Diesen Ladezyklus, von dem da immer gesprochen wird, das muss man nicht wirklich so ernst nehmen, als wirklich ein Power-Cycle, dass man ihn jetzt komplett auflädt und komplett entlädt, komplett auflädt. Das ist gar nicht mal gemeint. Also wir machen das mit dem Blygels relativ regelgross. Je nachdem, was ich da jetzt rausgezogen hab, wenn ich Steckdose hab, kommt er da ran.
Wie lange lädt der?
Voll geladen. Das sind schon 5-6 Stunden für so eine, was wir hier im Rechenbeispiel hatten. 5-6 Stunden für 25?
Diese Segways, die fahren aber weiter als 25 Kilometer, oder?
Das stinkt wahrscheinlich durch die Batterietechnik. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Volt die fahren, oder wie viel Wattstunde sie insgesamt an Bord haben für die Fahrt. Hab ich nichts gesehen.
Also 25 Kilometer, okay, ich meine so für die Stadt?
Das ist doch eins zu wenig.
Na gut, in Berlin wird es schon ein bisschen knapp.
Ja genau, wenn man wieder heim will, weil man nicht laden konnte, wo man hin wollte.
Mal in Spandau, Prenzlauer Berg hin und zurück, dann bleibt man unter Umständen liegen, aber so für kleinere Städte, aber fürs Land. Wo ist dann die eigentliche Frage?
Da muss man eben seine Strecke wissen, genau. Und ein bisschen Ladegerät vor Ort haben, also das, wo hatte ich es gemacht, das hätte es also.
Oder dann halt doch Fluxkompensator irgendwie, der neuere Generation, dann kann man auch Bananenschalen und so weiter reinschmeißen.
Kleine Taschenreaktoren und so, das ist logisch. Also die Stromquelle, das ist das A und O, das wird uns auf die ganze Zeit begleiten.
Gizmo, super Projekt, elektronenrad.de, wenn ihr noch ein bisschen nachgucken wollt. Dort ist auch ein Blog, wo nicht viel steht, aber vielleicht demnächst noch mehr auftaucht. Ab und zu gibt es was Neues, wenn ihr Fragen habt, könnt ihr euch sicherlich an dich wenden, oder?
Klar, alles erreichbar.
Ich bin gespannt zu sehen, dass da so eine ähnliche Vernetzung auch greift, wie das jetzt vor kurzem mit dem Quadrocop losgegangen ist. Auch noch mal ein Thema für Chaosradio Express. Schon vorgemerkt, aber noch nichts in Planung. Wie auch immer, aber auch so elektrische Fahrräder. Oder wie gesagt, so ein Segway.
Brauchen wir schon mal einen.
Wäre eigentlich mal ein cooles Kongressprojekt.
Das ist sowieso eine Leihstellung. Wir fragen mal an.
Nö, was heißt Leihstellung? Einfach selber bauen. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das so schwierig ist. Ich meine, mittlerweile, am Anfang war das überhaupt erst mal so dieses, naja, man muss ja diese Beschleunigungssensoren überhaupt erst mal in den Griff kriegen. Und keiner kannte das. Mittlerweile gibt es viele Leute, die das benutzen. Man kann die relativ günstig kaufen. So, und wenn man merkt, wie sich das Ding irgendwie austariert.
Potenzial, dass man dahinter kommt.
Also wenn man was zum Fliegen kriegt, dann kriegt man ja wohl auch noch was zum Stehen. Dann vielleicht eben auch zum Fahren. Und das wär dann was für ein Kongress. So ein Gerät, wo man sich drauf stellt und sagt irgendwie, ja, also hier, das ist das Konferenzprogramm, fahr mich einfach mal in Saal 1.
Sputnik haben wir ja sowieso, alles, was man braucht.
Genau, noch mit RFID-Tracking. Das System wird langsam komplett. Okay, ich denke, das war's. Chaosradio Express, 65, elektrische Fahrräder.
Vielen Dank, Gizmo.
Und wenn euch das gefallen hat, oder auch nicht, dann wie immer wisst ihr, Feedback ist gerne gesehen, Chaosradio lccc.de, da warten wir auf Nachrichten. Und natürlich gibt es das Blog, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de, wo zu jeder Sendung eigentlich immer einen Eintrag zu finden ist, wo man auch frisch und fleißig kommentieren kann. Und ja, wir sind auf Rückmeldungen immer gespannt und wollen das auch hören, damit es hier weitergeht, wie wir uns das gedacht haben, bei Chaosradio Express. Ich grüße euch, das war Tim Pritlove am 13. Januar 2008 und jetzt geht's bald weiter mit der nächsten Sendung. Derzeit ist hohe Sendungsdichte, so soll es auch sein. Nochmal danke Gizmo und tschüss, bis bald.